[Musica]
buonasera sono venuta qui a parlarvi di
felicità però la costerò parole che sono
un po inusuali che non siete abituati ad
ascoltare vicino a lei parleremo di
felicità e di bava di felicità e di
ausili violenti estremamente invasivi
sul corpo come le tracheostomia le
gastrostomia parleremo di felicità e
l'ha costretta a sonde sondini siringhe
ausili di ogni tipo protesi sedia a
rotelle accuseremo quindi parole che
siamo abituati a immaginare vicino al
dolore e alla sofferenza invece vi
assicuro che non perderemo mai di vista
la cosa più importante quella per cui
sono salita su questo palco la felicità
mi chiama valentina perniciaro o 40 anni
da quando era una bambina immaginavo di
cambiare il mondo di riscriverlo
completamente con parole che fossero di
uguaglianza di diritti di
autodeterminazione di libertà forse però
l'urgenza di questo cambiamento della
necessità proprio impellente di
costruire un mondo che sia veramente di
tutto e di tutti ha preso fuoco
veramente forma nella mia testa da poco
tempo quando ho riscritto dentro di me
intorno a me il concetto di felicità
appunto una felicità che coinvolge
qualunque tipo di corpo i corpi e le
menti non conformi che dà per scontato
che non ci sia nessuno che non abbia
diritto di costruire il proprio percorso
di vita il proprio percorso di autonomia
il diritto appunto essere parte attiva
della propria vita e anche della società
in cui si vive è complicato immaginare
di raccontare questo quando è realtà il
focus principale che avremo davanti è
una disabilità complessa anche io
appunto quella che voleva cambiare il
mondo avevo permesso all'etichetta
immensa della disabilità di quello che è
il nostro immaginario
stracolmo di stereotipi sulle
vulnerabilità e e la disabilità di
nascondere appunto con la sua grande
immensa enormità tutto quello che c'è
dietro questa parola la disabilità tutte
le persone i corpi che sono nascoste da
queste norme etichetta che siamo
abituati ad utilizzare tutti ognuno
nessuno escluso quando ci rapportiamo
con persone più vulnerabili siamo
abituati osservarle a immaginare che
siano competenza di qualcun altro che
facciano parte di un altro universo
siamo anche abituati a non vederle
perché spesso sono chiuse nelle loro
case io questo l'ho scoperto piano piano
ho scoperto in un giorno della mia vita
in cui il sole
quello di cui si parlava prima si è
spento all'improvviso non sono qui a
raccontarvi che esistono che ovviamente
non esistono bombe buone o intelligenti
esistono però bombe più più cattive più
infami di altre quelle che scoppiano in
quei luoghi e in quei posti dove mai
dovrebbe esplodere una bomba dove
proprio impensabile che possa avvenire
un'esplosione che dilani la felicità la
bomba che ha colpito me la mia famiglia
al mio immaginario di felicità è proprio
una di quelle con quelle che scoppiano
nei mercati affollati e ha colpito la
mia vita e il mio un punto quello che
ero riuscito a costruire l'immaginario
di felicità quando mio figlio aveva solo
50 giorni di vita e il suo cuore si è
fermato il mio secondo bambino sirio
durante i minuti in cui il cuore è stato
fermo come potete immaginare il danno
celebrale e avanzato e si è mangiato
pezzi di quelle che immaginavamo fossero
la sua e la nostra felicità
l'inizio del suo percorso dopo che è
stato stabilizzato quando abbiamo
ritrovato questo corpicino che sembrava
perfetto e che invece era
improvvisamente deformato intubato
attaccato probabilmente a vita dei
macchinari abbiamo cominciato appunto a
cercare di immaginare come ricalibrare
il nostro immaginario di felicità
circondati dai camici bianchi che
mutavano colore nei giorni successivi al
punto al suo arresto cardiaco da camici
bianchi e immacolati si trasformavano in
toghe nere le prime parole che hanno
cominciato a dirci del futuro di nostro
figlio era che sarebbe stato uno stato
vegetativo perenne che non avrebbe mai
preso coscienza
sono parole indimenticabili del mondo
intorno a lui e anche di noi dell'amore
che c'era intorno a lui del pianeta che
lo circondava quindi dovevamo
ricalibrare il nostro immaginario su
punto una vita priva di colori priva
proprio dell'idea che il vento potesse
passare tra i suoi capelli quindi
insomma un completamente un ricalibrarsi
quake amici che all'improvviso erano
diventati toghe nere di giudici che
sentenziavano una condanna a vita poi ci
sono mente trasformati sono diventati i
camici azzurrini del mondo della
neuroriabilitazione dove siamo finiti un
mondo che assolutamente non conoscevamo
quella che abbiamo ri soprannominato la
grande falegnameria della
neuroriabilitazione dove abbiamo
incontrato quelli che chiamiamo geppetti
cioè uomini e donne che vedono in dei
tronchi di legno in dei piccoli pezzi di
legno immobile e quello era mio figlio
dei bambini loro già hanno questa grande
capacità di scorgere nel legno immobile
un profumo di un legno da scolpire di
bambini completamente da ricostruire da
ridisegnare da re immaginare parte della
società non sono qui a raccontarvi
quello che sono stati gli otto anni
quasi 9 ormai di percorso di vita di
sirio di sconfitte in sconfitte
precipizi e cadute sir e ora appunto è
un bambino di quasi nove anni la cui
diagnosi era molto lunga
il cucciolo cuore fermo ovviamente ha
comportato ora una situazione dopo un
anno di permanenza in ospedale che lo
rende ovviamente
incapace appunto a prendersi cura di se
stesso e una persona che avrà sempre
necessità di essere assistito h24 come
avete visto anche nelle immagini e dalle
prime parole che vi ho detto il suo
corpo è insomma completato da una serie
di ausili che vanno gestiti molto con in
modo molto complicato e che ovviamente
ha sbaragliato anche tutto quello che
era la nostra famiglia prima tutto
quello che era la quotidianità della
nostra vita dentro casa ripeto non sono
venuta qui a raccontarvi pezzo pezzo
quello che è stato il nostro percorso
quello per stato anche il percorso di
silio di riappropriarsi un po del suo
percorso di autodeterminazione
siamo venuti qui comunque a parlare di
felicità a cercare di presentarvi
l'imperfezione dei corpi la non
conformità di corpi e di menti che pure
invece desiderano hanno la necessità è
l'obiettivo di video essere parti attive
della società di essere veramente
inseriti nel mondo che viviamo noi
questi esercito di sbilenchi di bimbi
bavosi
particolarmente storti ci siamo proprio
andato a cercare abbiamo cercato di
dargli un nome l'abbiamo rifondato con
questo concerto dei the tra bondi
piccoli vagabondi tetraplegici che
possano finalmente riappropriarsi delle
strade del mondo le scuole del mondo dei
parchi dei socializzare con ognuno di
noi di voi siamo appunto iniziati a
nascere sui social con una con una
battaglia di presenza proprio per
raccontare che appunto il mondo se
vogliamo immaginarlo diverso se vogliamo
piano immaginarlo in un percorso di
cambiamento non può certo escludere
qualcuno non può certo immaginarsi
libero e capace di mutare se esclude
qualcuno non possiamo certo più
permettere che la segregazione
el'emarginazione
coinvolto un portino tutta completamente
la vita delle persone che hanno delle
disabilità dei bisogni speciali
abbiamo cominciato a cercare di
rivoluzionare le parole è quello che
voglio fare stasera con voi prendere
tutte le parole che per secoli sono
state utilizzate per descrivere la
disabilità alle vulnerabilità le
fragilità l'imperfezione del corpo e
della mente umana è accartocciata
insieme a voi buttarle nella pattumiera
della storia dove invece per secoli sono
stati proprio gli storti venuti male
svilenti quelli che magari dalla bocca
hanno un po di bava e quindi fanno un po
senso nel mondo è invece hanno tanto da
dare hanno tanto soprattutto da
insegnare proprio per far capire che il
mondo e la disabilità non è che un
appunto una peculiarità dell'essere
umano che non possiamo far finta di non
notare che non possiamo fare finta di
non capire che è parte integrante della
società e della vita di ognuno di noi
appunto l'esercito dei tra bondi ci ha
insegnato che riappropriarsi di un
concetto di felicità collettiva è un
percorso meraviglioso e abbiamo cercato
di ribaltare le parole anche quelle che
spesso vengono usate in buona fede
quando si parla di disabilità
soprattutto quando si parla di bambini
siamo abituati a immaginare nel punto
nel nostro modo di parlare dei bimbi
speciali dei bimbi speciali che se
continuiamo immaginare tali e non bimbi
normali con dei bisogni speciali
sicuramente non li immaginiamo adulti
non immaginiamo parte della società che
incontriamo parte del mondo che vogliamo
costruire
chiamarli bambini speciali comporta
immaginare che ci siano dietro delle
madri martiri magari un madri coraggio
che sono destinate ad accudire queste
vite a vita senza poi riuscire a fruire
mai anche delle relazioni sociali che
spesso in situazioni del genere e
saltano completamente quindi siamo
venuti proprio a ribaltare questo a
spiegare che di speciale non c'è mai
nessuno che le vite sono vite che tutti
aspirano costruire un proprio percorso
di felicità che di speciale ci sono i
bisogni ai bisogni si può rispondere ai
bisogni si trovano strumenti pensate che
sirio avevano detto tra le tante
sentenze che gli erano stati dati che
non avrebbe avuto mai prerequisiti per
comunicare che malgrado i suoi progressi
motori la sua capacità di sbloccare quel
corpicino immobile che sembrava
assolutamente sbloccabile secondo questi
grandi illuminare non c'era nessuna
possibilità di strappare lui
l'intenzionalità i desideri la sua
appunto la sua capacità di rispondere si
e no questo è stato sbaragliato pensate
da due elastici per capelli
questo per farvi capire come poi
costruire strumenti che rispondono ai
bisogni spesso è solo frutto di no di un
intuito di un intelligenza di un'equipe
che si inventa un qualcosa di
personalizzato sul bisogno sirio ha
iniziato a dire sì e no con due elastici
per capelli mese ai suoi polsi minuscoli
era piccolo quindi un elastico verde che
lui lentamente indicava per dire il suo
sì è un elastico rosso per dire il suono
ci sono voluti due anni e mezzo per
mettere quelli elastici ai polsi di
sirio e invece abbiamo capito
immediatamente che sirio capiva quello
che gli dicevamo sapeva rispondere aveva
i suoi desideri quindi sapeva dirci sì
voglio fare qualcosa
non voglio fare questa cosa quello è
stato il suo modo verdi ci ci sono ci
sono anch'io voglio far parte del mondo
ovviamente dopo di questo il bisogno
proprio di rivoluzionario quello che
c'era intorno a noi è diventato il re
frenabile quindi mettere su questo
piccolo esercito di tetra bondi così
appunto gli abbiamo voluto chiamare è
stato proprio un cercare di insegnare la
bellezza dei bisogni e soprattutto degli
strumenti che ci sono di risposta a
questo la capacità appunto di immaginare
che non ci possano essere vite che siano
destinate solo alla cura l'assistenza
ancor più della famiglia ma che ci sia
appunto un bisogno di percepire che
dietro ogni corpo e dietro ogni mente
anche quelle assolutamente non conformi
c'è appunto un qualcuno che vuole
costruire il proprio percorso di
autodeterminazione che vuole comunque
far vedere al mondo che dietro c'è un
suo carattere i suoi desideri immaginare
che anche i corpi non perfetti siano
corpi desideranti vi assicuro che una
rivoluzione bellissima che permette a
ognuno di noi di fare un grande salto di
capire che appunto se vogliamo
immaginare un cambiamento un vero
cambiamento ed è vero che è il momento
adatto per immaginarlo non può certo non
passare non essere attraversato da
qualunque corpo appunto anche non
conforme in modo che ognuno a modo suo
possa costruire il suo percorso e possa
dimostrare al mondo che la felicità è un
è una responsabilità collettiva
necessita la partecipazione di ognuno di
voi per costruire un mondo capace non
escludere più i più deboli c'è
ovviamente bisogno che nessuno si tiri
indietro la costruzione di questo che
ognuno di voi si impari a riconoscere i
bisogni a capire quanti sono gli
strumenti che già ci sono quanto
meravigliosi sono quanti saranno quelli
che possiamo inventarci insieme per
rispondere ai bisogni più disparati e
per costruire un mondo che sia veramente
di tutti e tutti dove ognuno a modo suo
possa costruire la sua strada grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]